Hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen beim ein video leute ich hoffe euch geht es  gut irgendwie
Fällt  mir ist gerade mal auf meine haare ich habe die vor ungefähr eineinhalb monaten oder zwei monaten blond gefärbt es ist eigentlich
Komplett wieder weg warum wachsen die  so schnell ja ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut in den letzten zwei
Tagen kam jetzt kein video ich war noch etwas in münchen
Habe es deswegen nicht geschafft dieses video zum beispiel habe ich schon etwas länger geplant
Aber es  irgendwie erst  jetzt auf die reihe bekommen also ich hab ja ab und zu mal mein snapchat auf  öffentlich das heißt
Jeder kann mir dort snap schicken also wenn ihr mich dann noch nicht geaddet . Habt  dann macht  das jetzt schnell
Dreieinhalb und man kriegt ja wirklich ab und zu sachen zugeschickt die sind wirklich komplett
Krank manche sachen sind auch echt lustig aber manchmal denke ich mir, halt echt
Warum? ihr habt es  wahrscheinlich, am titel schon gelesen heute geht es um die zehn schlimmsten
Snapshot post von so rich kids also
Halt so abgehobene wichser die halt wirklich ziemlich reiche eltern haben und das auch öffentlich so auf social media zeigen
Und eigentlich indirekt sagen wollen ich bin geil als du natürlich wird das ist auch nicht zu negativ darstellen
Vieles davon ist doch echt witzig aber einige sachen dann schon echt krass und das muss dann will ich auch nicht sein
Leute ich will eigentlich gar nicht lange lagern nun bevor wir anfangen wollte gar nicht sagen am sonntag
kommt endlich ein video wir haben da glaube ich drei monate dran gesessen hier mal ein ganz kurzer ausschnitt
Es ist auf jeden fall dass geilste video geworden was je auf youtube hochgeladen wurde
Und er freut sich auf sonntag ich bin schon ziemlich gespannt wie's löchern kommen
Okay, leute wir fangen an mit dem ersten snap den nicht gefunden habe und zwar
Ist es dieser hier wanted weapons
Sack also auf deutsch übersetzt ich wollte ihnen gelten meine eltern nerven mich schon wieder so und zwar haben wir hier einen lamborghini in grün
Das problem ist nur er wollte lieber geld haben
Das ist wirklich so ein problem
Ich kann es auch komplett nachvollziehen ich meine ist bei mir genauso wenn man mir in la bohème stellt der grün ist eher
Das geht doch nicht ehrlich leute das geht nicht. Da bist du dumm das ding kostet keine ahnung 200 300.000 euro
Und du willst gelb dann las ich jedoch umlackieren für 1000 euro beim gold also da kann man, sich echt
zu fragen wie können eltern
Ihr kind so erziehen dass es so wenig weiß mit geld umzugehen paar leute kommen wir zum nächsten foto oder das ist das hier auf
deutsch
Übersetzt ich könnte mich nicht entscheiden körper hat mir alle fünf geholt also normalerweise wenn man ein iphone hat und sich eine hülle dazu kauft
Kann man sich eine farbe aussuchen problem hierbei ist nur um das ist das iphone 5 c
Und das gab's halt in fünf verschiedenen farben
Also weiß gelb grün blau und rot anscheinend wusste der papa dann nicht welches die lieblingsfarbe ist und dachte sich com kaufe ich einfach
Mal alle fünf also dafür mehr ich dir heute das nächste foto ist dieses hier knüpft eigentlich ziemlich dazu an und zwar
hat er hier anscheinend ein neues
iphone bekommen und was kann man natürlich besseres machen als ein altes iphone zu verkaufen oder vielleicht an jemanden, zu verschenken
Da nicht, so viel geld hat richtig eine fette champagner flasche kaufen und diese als bilder tür. Benutzen und das iphone zerstören
Und das wichtigste ist natürlich den autoschlüssel noch schön auf dem bild zu
positionieren aktion die uhr darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
kommen wir zum nächsten bild das fand ich eigentlich sogar echt ziemlich
Lustig und zwar haben wir hier ein ganz normales spiel also ihr kennt wahrscheinlich ist es länger spielt wo man
Halt diese katze starb das foto entstand an einer privaten schule das heißt eine schule man
Geld bezahlen muss und auch so privatschulen sind dann meistens auch kinder
Wo die eltern etwas zu viel geld haben ich meine man
Muss ja auch nicht auf eine schule gehen wo man kein geld bezahlen muss und die dachten sicher kommen spielen wir mal alles schön
Mit unseren iphones länger ich mein wenn das kaputtgeht
kaufen halten neues so lautet das nächste foto ist dieses hier finde ich eigentlich auch ziemlich lustig und zwar schreibt
Er dazu ich hoffe der mathelehrer akzeptiert das so dem ist anscheinend das papier ausgegangen
Und was macht man wenn man kein papier hat richtig man schreibt einfach aufs ipad wahrscheinlich auch noch
Mit einem permanent marker jetzt muss ich aber mal kurz mal durchrechnen ob du richtig gerechnet hast
Nein das kann schon gar nicht sein die erste tat bot doch doch doch du
Glaubst das ist richtig es eher was so für die neunte klasse
Aber ja ist richtig so leute hier ist das nächste foto und dazu. Muss ich erst mal sagen
Schönes foto nur im t shirt zu produzieren und irgendwas drauf zu drucken kann ja eigentlich fast jeder wenn da aber so leichtsinnig draufsteht
Stop being tue also hört auf arm zu sein ich habe sie sich ganz einfach dann hat sie auch noch, so chanel luftballons
Ist ja eine relativ teure marke und ich glaube das bad ist auch relativ cool sogar mit kamin
im hintergrund aber mädel ich kann dir sagen
Es gibt auch menschen die kommen auf die welt und haben nicht sofort reiche eltern
Und da bringt es auch nichts wenn man sich ein t-shirt anzieht
Wo draufsteht höher auf arm zu sein na ja da ist das nächste bild finde
Ich echt geil und zwar louis vitton erkennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle ist eine relativ exklusive marke wenn man sich der tasche oder rucksack
Auf ist man schnell mal so mit 17 dabei hatte 1000 euro für eine tasche oder rucksack
Ist schon relativ sportlich wenn man dann aber überhaupt nicht weiß was mit seinem
geld anstellen soll richtig dann lässt man sich einfach ein football von louis vitton
Anfertigen ich google jetzt mal kurz wie teuer das ding ist also ich habe jetzt nur einen motor fußball gefunden also kein futter sondern
Fußball gut ist ja eigentlich auch ein football aber ihr seht wahrscheinlich ein unterschied und das ding kostet
1500 euro
für den fußball der wahrscheinlich nicht mal gut ist
aber
Dass wenn ich wenigstens doch lustig so leute und das hier ist das nächste foto da schreibt jemand
Dort treibt person food also diese wörter pässen food deute ich so ein bisschen
Abwertendes essen so bauern es mäßig was halt so sich irgendwie. Jeder leisten kann also in diesem beispiel
Halt mehr donald erhält hat seine rolex davor und posthalter übels arrogant
Hey komm ich dachte ich probiere auch mal dieses bauern essen dick leiter
Ich hoffe die spucken die richtig auf den big mac so leicht und kommt zum schluss zu meinem favoriten
crashs ersten driving das
Ist jetzt halt nur in bentley kostet 100.000 weniger aber trotzdem noch über
100000 world problems auf jeden fall kenne ich ich bin auch manchmal meinem auto und denkt scheiße
Das heißt sie gestern erst den lambo kaputt gemacht hast du heute nun
Muss sagen das leben kann echt so gemein sein er sollte das waren meine zehn schlimmsten
Snapshot post von spitz die ich so ermitteln konnte wenn ihr bock hat er sich das ganze auch mit instagram rich kids mache last man
doch nach oben da bei
ich bin
mal gespannt wie viele lecks verschaffen und dann kommt der nächste projekt auf jeden fall snapshot und fenster gemacht und wir sehen uns dann
morgen wieder fahren gibt es ein cooles neues video also haut rein 15 uhr einschalten es kommt immer um 15 uhr